how are you doing today sir
hey good better haul off we only got
five minutes
wait believe me it kills me i could have
all right
um so jumping right in i just want to
say congrats on this series
uh i'm so happy it was made do you think
that at some point humans will be able
to
understand what whales are saying and
what do we need to do to make this
happen
i don't see why not i think that if we
used
ai deep learning and you give it a big
enough data set
of whale recordings that are closely
linked
with visual observations of what they're
doing
what what social behavior they're
engaged in at the moment
i think that a deep learning algorithm
could start to figure out ways to
communicate
with uh with whales i don't know if
anybody's working on this but i can't
imagine a reason why
if you don't have enough data on the
problem but the trick is to
observe them continuously and for long
periods of time in a way that's not
intrusive and doesn't change their
behavior
because otherwise you might find out
that they're just talking about the
the skinny weird pink monkey people that
are coming into the water with them
completely um there's a lot of content
out there right now a lot of choices
why do you want people to tune into this
series
look i think all these choices and all
this all this
wonderful entertainment media that's
coming out at us just helps build that
pink floyd wall between us and nature
right and a lot of people choose to
pierce that wall
by going on a journey into nature and
some of the
some of the high-end beautiful natural
history photography
series have done very well over the last
few years because people feel that lack
you know so our goal with with this
series of films was to
remind people how fantastic whales are
and teach them something new and to do
that we had to find out something new
right it was investigative and there
were researchers involved and we
observed behavior that had never been
seen before and i think that's very
exciting and also to remind us what we
love
about these sentient caring emotional
animals that share this planet with us
and whom we're
sort of pushing to the edge of
extinction it breaks my heart
what do you wish people knew about wales
that maybe they don't know
i think i i think the what i wish and
what the goal of the series represents
is to
show people that whales are if we if we
want to put it in
like our egocentric terms or
anthropocentric terms
they're very human in the way that they
use
language the way that they use music the
way that they interact socially the way
they
have bonds of love generational bonds
parents and children
that they grieve that they're much more
like us than
than just these sort of big majestic and
enigmatic
animals and and that and if that causes
people to sort of fall even more in love
with whales then they'll they'll have a
greater tendency to make
whatever choices need to be made with
for us as a civilization
to keep them alive something that i
admire about
all of your work uh is the way you use
technology
to further enhance your storytelling
ability
obviously i'm hugely looking forward to
the avatar sequels
and i'm just wondering how you've been
able to take
new technology to help tell these
stories
well the the work that i've done in the
ocean has been very tech forward you
know obviously building submersible
vehicles robotics
advanced lighting 3d cameras and so on
this series was less that and used a lot
of the conventional tools but they
pushed the tool set
by creating remote cameras that could
stick down from boats and
and do some elegant imaging of pods on
the move remote cameras that could be
set in place
so that they had they were not intrusive
into the the whale's psychology
when the belugas were doing their
various behaviors in
shallow water in those shoaling grounds
where they they go for their
their big annual you know 2000 strong
meetups
you know uh remote cameras replace their
drones were used and so on so
um the natural history photographers on
this show were definitely pushing
the edge of the tech envelope to get
some of these images
and it's tough because you know if
you're shooting a polar bear on an ice
floe you can use an 800 millimeter lens
and shoot them from a mile away
but with whales in the water medium
generally speaking you've got to be in
there with them
so there's a psychological component to
it as well you have to understand what
they're thinking
and not drive them away or be in some
way intrusive so that you're
observing behavior that's not abnormal
for them
completely i already have to go i'm just
going to say congrats on this
i know it's crazy and um have a
fantastic day
thank you for giving me next time next
time we'll talk more
hopefully i'm going to hold you through
that okay no problem